c'est un médecin elle est intelligente et
très sensible et humaine c'est
une veuve italienne avec des secrets son
futur mari a été tué et elle risque que
la même chose arrive à son
inspecteur les deux femmes avec qui il se
connecte ont toutes les deux un grand mystère elles ont toutes les deux
des profondeurs et  pour cela, vous avez besoin d'
actrices fantastiques et j'ai juste pensé que
Monica Bellucci, vous savez, a du
sens dans une histoire, a du sens pour l'
âge des personnages auxquels ils ont affaire
et elle est vous savez une présence incroyablement séduisante
dans la vie et dans le film et
je suis ravi qu'elle soit  dedans James Bond fait
partie de l'histoire du cinéma et je respecte
tellement toutes les James Bond girls parce que je
pense qu'il y a des actrices incroyables et
maintenant on a moins adieu elle est très
belle et très talentueuse et c'est une
grande James Bond girl
Madeline personnage qui  Laird est clairement
nécessaire pour être fougueux et
compliqué et je pense que c'est une
relation essentielle, donc cela n'aurait probablement pas
pu être un nouveau venu total nécessaire
quelqu'un avec une certaine
maturité d'expérience de vie et elle est le genre
de package complet vraiment je me sens très
chanceux je pense que je travaille juste avec des
acteurs incroyables un réalisateur incroyable et ça a
été une belle aventure